okay since we're doing a read-along
style so the folks at home can follow
along if you grab issue one of Batman
cacophony but when we get to the end of
every page I'll be narrating or reading
those boxes and whatnot picking up a
character here too but when we get to
the end of the page you will know it's
time to turn the page when you hear the
sound of the beep which goes like this
yeah it's gonna be sounding like this
now because that file is not loading
okay so we're gonna turn to our guest
star no we're gonna turn you're here man
so can you no we don't need an echo so
just to Boop you like I'll give you
something from [ __ ] Skywalker's
library all you have to do is simply go
boom like a defining sound is the signal
to turn the page toiling all right so
that means follow along so you'll know
when it's time to turn it pays off not
you and you go as high as you can
your isn't going explained at all we're
baking up as we go along that's the fun
it's fun it's loose its organizational
we've never done it ladies and gentlemen
for the first time ever we're gonna try
to perform a comic book here we go
another one of these please get them
three here we go the Arkham Asylum for
the criminally insane we're outside the
gates of Arkham as you could see the
mental hospital where all the bad guys
go following the recent nationwide
economic crash as car as a cost-cutting
measure the board opted to discontinue
security guards at the front gate and
suddenly there's a gun shot takes a
camera out I'll take it yeah yeah yeah
I'll take it from you good give me let
me hear it again that but give me better
than Pataki that's a sound effect on
nice and now give me breaking glass it's
a cute version of these
the rationale was that nobody ever wants
to break into Arkham the board divided
up sixty thousand dollars savings
amongst themselves and year-end bonuses
and what we see is a dark figure
climbing over the fence of Arkham Asylum
into the page and was returned to the
end of the page we hear the sound that
means turn the page and that is nicely
done so far so good man don't applaud
every page I'll be a long night oh yeah
longtime front gate guard Sam Jennings
Android Kelly were forced to look for
work in a job market that as little left
little use left for employees over 50
when his unemployment benefits ran out
Sam filed for government assistance his
wife now forced to use food stamps at
their neighborhood supermarket regularly
berates Sam for bringing her so low Roy
however always the more industrious of
the two took out an ad in the Gotham
Gazette personal section that ran every
day for two months former Arkham
security guard seeks employment or other
the listing red 30 years experience in
the world's most dangerous and secure
penal institution inquiries contact box
1145 we see our shadowy figure outside
the building pull a grappling hook out
from his overcoat and he shoots it nice
and it catches presumably up top and he
gets lifted up sorry my voice is
cracking want a drink yeah I leave you
guys alone
for you to share two straws we're gonna
share a plate of spaghetti in a minute
you a whiz Luna right on here we go
grappling hook goes up named up to a
spaceship that's a grappling hook
already you have problems with the cab I
know it's like every film you've ever
made just this day it's fine this is cop
out all over there
[Music]
you
[Music]